ce samedi 4 mars c'est la journée
mondiale de l'obésité en évènement pour
sensibiliser à cette maladie qui touche
de plus en plus de personnes en France
et dans le monde à cette occasion
l'association poids plumes France
organise des rendez-vous dans quatre
centres spécialisés dans la prise en
charge de l'obésité notamment à
l'Institut Mutualiste Montsouris de
Paris et au centre hospitalier de
Rambouillet pour en parler Claudine
canalet présidente de l'association
poids plumes France et Angélique la font
cadre de santé au centre hospitalier de
Rambouillet bonsoir alors près d'un
Français sur deux est touché par
l'obésité et le surpoids selon une
récente étude de la ligue contre
l'obésité et l'Inserm alors quel est
l'objectif de cette journée Claudine
canalet est-ce que c'est rappelé que
l'obésité est avant tout une maladie oui
alors ça il faut vraiment le marteler il
faut que les gens prennent conscience
qu'en fait c'est pas le fait de rester
sur son canapé ou de manger pas sain que
on devient gros c'est beaucoup plus
complexe que ça la maladie obésité
effectivement ben c'est une maladie
multifactorielle et il faut qu'elle soit
vraiment prise en charge très tôt pour
effectivement essayer de la contourner
et alors comment se fait dépister alors
on va voir déjà son médecin traitant il
y a différents
centres on peut aller voir son médecin
traitant je pense que le médecin
traitant joue un rôle très important il
y a aussi les tous les services les CPTs
les CMS qui sont là aussi pour aider et
accompagner alors centre alors je me
rappelle plus CMS et centre médical de
santé et CPTs et je pense c'est une
plateforme qui oriente effectivement qui
est tout un réseau qui oriente les
personnes en situation d'obésité
d'accord
donc la journée est aussi très
importante donc c'est toujours le 4 mars
ça ne changera pas c'est une journée
mondiale c'est pour sensibiliser
effectivement la population au regard
des personnes qui sont en situation
d'obésité il y a différentes façons de
la prendre en charge et donc je on
accompagne ces passions aussi au sein de
au CHU de Rambouillet pour effectivement
prévenir et accompagner les personnes
qui désirent se faire prendre en charge
donc on parlera un petit peu plus tard
de cette série en charge par l'hôpital
de Rambouillet elle touche de plus en
plus de Français et aussi de plus en
plus de jeunes depuis
1997 l'obésité a été multipliée par 4
chez les 18 24 ans la situation est
préoccupante et alarmante parce que si
on fait pas quelque chose si les
pouvoirs publics te rendent pas compte
qu'il faut vraiment
dédier de l'argent sur la recherche sur
ces différentes choses on avancera pas
en fait et ça devient très très complexe
alors le thème de cette année c'est
changing perspective changeons de
perspectives changeons les regards en
français on entend souvent des
stéréotypes du genre il est obèse parce
qu'il mange mal ou parce qu'il fait pas
assez de sport cette journée elle sert
aussi à ça à casser ses préjugés donc il
y aura effectivement à l'Institut
Montsouris 4 conférences qui vont être
autour de ça donc la première table
ronde sera sur le dépistage comment on
se fait disputer il y aura le deuxième
tableau ronde justement tout un focus
c'est quoi la grossophobie donc il y a
beaucoup de choses qui sont sortis
actuellement sur la grossophobie ensuite
les parcours de soins commencent prend
en charge et pour finir et ben quelles
sont les perspectives d'avenir justement
chirurgie ou pas comment on accompagne
les patients vers quelle direction on
les envoie
Régine vous avez une question oui
justement vous disiez que l'obésité
pouvait être pouvait être
multifactorielle que justement on a ce
préjugé de dire c'est parce qu'on mange
mal qu'on est obèse et à votre avis quel
serait les autres facteurs comment
est-ce que ça explique il y a
l'endocrinologie il y a tout ce qui est
l'environnement il y a effectivement
le manger facile le manger non sain le
manger rapide mais il y a des effets
psychologiques il y a des quand on
interroge et quand on échange avec des
personnes qui sont en situation
d'obésité on se dit ouh là c'est
compliqué ils ont des passifs très
lourds surtout dans l'adolescence et
pour ça que des discriminations des
regards
on se construit une carapace
effectivement pour se protéger de tout
ça et c'est compliqué et
il y a pas que la diététique et
malheureusement pas que l'activité
physique effectivement bah le fait aussi
qui a des jeux vidéo ces films et tout
ça ça va pas ranger on va rester en
sédentarité on va rester sur son canapé
mais l'objectif c'est effectivement de
d'aider des adolescents à se mettre en
activité et ça a été aussi une une un
champ de direction pour notre journée
nous avons développé une application
pour mettre en marche justement plein de
personnes autour de cette journée qui a
démarré depuis le 18 février c'est
l'application JMO Gémeaux le défi des
jumeaux voilà voilà qu'on a appelé comme
ça parce que je trouvais que c'est le
principe de cette application
et on marche par centre on est soit
rattaché à centre médical ou pas
l'objectif c'est effectivement celui qui
réalise le plus grand nombre de pas et
donc il y aura un gagnant homme et femme
il y aura deux gagnants en fait et après
il y aura un gagnant au niveau des
centres hospitaliers qui auront
effectivement
aider à mettre les gens en marche alors
angélique la fin de l'association foie
plume France travaille avec des centres
spécialisés comme celui de l'hôpital de
Rambouillet qu'est-ce qui est fait sur
place concrètement alors concrètement
nous on organise des groupes de travail
et de paroles donc en lien avec
l'association poids plumes qui sont des
en fait des retours de patients experts
donc c'est très important au niveau de
la prise en charge de l'obésité voilà on
travaille en nous on a monté donc ce
service de chirurgie bariatrique en 2020
et donc du coup on a très rapidement on
s'est bien donc avec l'association poids
plumes et effectivement donc on a un
passeport de de prise en charge qui
accompagne le patient tout au long de
son parcours donc ce soit médical ou
chirurgical et dedans nous avons du coup
le plaquettes de l'association poids
plume pour voilà leur donner des petites
clés des savoir où s'adresser pas qu'en
interne mais aussi au niveau associatif
et alors pour la Journée mondiale de
l'obésité qui aura lieu samedi quel est
quel est le problème quel est le
programme à l'hôpital de Rambouillet
alors un super programme
donc bon nous c'est la première année
qu'on participe donc à cette journée
mondiale de l'obésité donc en
coordination donc avec l'association
poids plume on a aussi la GMR que
l'association gym de marche de
Rambouillet qui voilà a participé
activement aussi du coup à l'application
des filles JMO et si on est en lien avec
le centre spécialisé de l'obésité
Île-de-France ouest et donc nous avons
un programme ou le matin on va
retransmettre donc les conférences qui
auront lieu un institut Montsouris avec
un petit voilà un petit accueil et
l'après-midi nous avons mis en place des
ateliers donc un premier atelier donc
quiz sur la diététique très ludique on a
essayé de casser les codes pour que ce
soit rigolo et que les gens s'amusent
aussi tout en passant des messages pour
sensibiliser les gens et aussi comme
disait Claudine voilà qui a démontré un
peu les codes casser les codes certains
codes donc voilà je vous en dirai pas
plus il faut que les gens viennent et
ils y participent après aussi on aura
une période où il y a des stands où en
fait on a nos professionnels de santé
donc les médecins donc les chirurgiens
l'endocrinologue la psychologue la
diététicienne et voilà tous les
intervenants qui seront sur place aussi
l'association hgmr qui va venir aussi
parce que nous on a un partenariat avec
eux justement dans notre service de
chirurgie bariatrique pour essayer de
stimuler les gens aussi à aller marcher
et que c'est pas parce qu'on est en
surpoids qu'on ne peut pas aller faire
de la Ran voilà donc il y a des choses
qui sont adaptées du coup à nos patients
et voilà donc et après aussi on a un
atelier plein de conscience avec Nolwenn
notre psychologue qui du coup sur tout
pour la l'atelier immersif pour prendre
conscience de son corps et de voir un
petit peu où on se situe et puis on
terminera par du yoga si si c'est
possible voilà vraiment pluridiscipliné
en fait
on a fait examen aussi un film sur les
deux parcours sur le parcours médical et
le parcours chirurgical pour présenter
l'équipe et rassurer les patients ok
merci beaucoup à toutes les deux pour
d'être venu d'avoir accepté notre
invitation en plateau un dernier mot
peut-être qu'est-ce qui ferait de cette
journée une journée réussie selon vous
qu'on comprenne que c'est déjà une
maladie et qu'on arrête de congom ces
idées reçues que c'est on ne marchant
pas et en mangeant mal que on est on
devient
une personne en situation d'obésité et
juste pour vous dire aussi que ça sera
retransmis sur tous les réseaux sociaux
on n'a pas dit et que
et que ben on attend beaucoup de monde
voilà ça sera ça voilà ça sera ça notre
réussite et bien merci beaucoup Claudine
cannelle angélique la fondament accepté
notre invitation je le rappelle du coup
le samedi 4 mars c'est la journée
mondiale de l'obésité des conférences
des ateliers et des animations seront
organisées par l'association poids
plumes France durant la journée
notamment à Paris et à l'hôpital de
Rambouillet